george clooney recently returned from a
trip to sudan
he talked about it in rising tensions in
that country at the council on foreign
relations
mr clooney is joined by human rights
activist john prendergast
of the enough project southern sudan is
scheduled to hold an independence
referendum in january
as part of a peace agreement between the
north and south
this is an hour please
oh we're miked hi
welcome everyone i'm tami holtman from
allafrica.com
also welcome to council on foreign
relations members who are joining us
from around the country by
teleconference
i need to make a couple of announcements
please completely turn off your cell
phones not just put them on vibrate or
silent because
we don't want interference with the
sound system
unlike most council sessions this one
happily is on the record so
spread the word
i'm turning off my phone hang on i
didn't hear a word you said
i'm going to do just a brief scene
center and introduce our guests and ask
them a couple things before opening
questions up to you it's 89 days
until the people of southern sudan are
scheduled to vote on whether to become
an independent country
a 2005 comprehensive peace accord or cpa
ended a 22-year war between sudan's
mostly muslim north and largely
christian south
that killed an estimated 2 million
people and displaced
twice that many the cpa laid out a
detailed process leading to the
referendum
including a parallel vote in the oil
rich obey area
on the north-south border but five years
and eight months later
many of the central issues are
unresolved including
demarcating the border establishing a
referendum commission
and determining who's eligible to vote
this is a problem
sudan is roughly the size of the united
states east of the mississippi
the south is about the size of france
with only about 50 kilometers of paved
roads
heavily armed troops are facing off in
disputed areas
and president omar al-bashir who was
re-elected in april has been indicted
for war crimes
by the international criminal court for
the government's actions in sudan's
darfur region
with time running out before the
referendum and the expectation that the
south
will vote for separation there's a
flurry of activity right now
at the united nations last month dozens
of international leaders including
president obama discussed
how to keep peace in sudan a security
council mission has just concluded a
visit
while a delegation from the u.s
holocaust museum has called for urgent
action to prevent
mass atrocities a spectrum of religious
leaders from sudan and
africa have ramped up an international
effort to ring alarm bells as they say
meeting yesterday in new york with u.n
secretary general ban
ki-moon and warning of a ticking time
bomb
u.s special envoy scott grayson and
mediator princeton lymon have been
meeting in ethiopia
with leaders from north and south to try
to break the deadlock
but those talks broke down today this
evening we have two people who have
devoted substantial time and energy to
sedan issues
to help us sort through the problems and
to point to possibilities for peace
i'm not going to do a lengthy
introduction because we want to hear
from them
but i'll just say and you have longer
bios in your handouts
john prendergast is an author and human
rights activist who's worked for peace
in africa for over 25 years
he's the co-founder of the enough
project an initiative to end
genocide and crimes against humanity
among many other
involvements he was director for africa
at the national security council
george clooney is a multi-award-winning
actor producer executive producer
screenwriter and director
he's the son of an anchorman
nick clooney and he's a strong first
amendment advocate with a deep
commitment to humanitarian causes
and as i think you all know they're both
just back from sudan
and also just at the end of a very long
day of meetings
which included president obama several
senators
and uh i don't know who all else but
speaker the house we spoke to on the
phone and uh senator terry
senator what message did you send why
don't you start george
well the first thing we wanted to say
was um
i think we're all sort of catching up a
little bit late to the idea that
there's about 90 days and uh and there's
an opportunity to prevent
atrocities instead of sort of mopping up
the mess after they happen
and uh you know i'm not a policymaker my
job is
uh you know cameras tend to follow me
where i go so we figure
then let's bring them all to the south
sudan and let them take pictures
but mostly what we're trying to do is uh
and what we said to senator luger and
senator kerry and to
speaker pelosi and certainly to the
president was
obviously what this is going to require
is uh diplomacy robust
intricate complicated diplomacy but it
also has to be done
quickly and if we're going to avoid
what we have seen happen twice before
with the same players
in the north south and in darfur uh we
can't just sit back and
think well if we just let it play out
maybe this time it will be better
it's sort of doubtful with so many
things at stake including oil so we just
thought
our our position was that we're going to
do everything we can to
help assist including creating public
will
and uh and some support to try and get
this
out enough to say um the
this you know that that the people of
this country the people of the world
uh are watching and aware and know that
uh if we do nothing that there's a very
good chance that
hundreds of thousands of people could
die innocent people and that was sort of
our message to them and asked what we
could do
to help to help get that message and
help them
move forward you've been there several
times now john you've been engaged in
sudan for a long time there's been five
years to
implement this cpa why just now and
what's what's going to change has there
not been
robust diplomacy as it were over the
past few years
where did the ball get dropped that's
the ball got dropped the day that the
peace agreement was signed january
2005 a tremendous extraordinary
accomplishment of the bush
administration to
along with their partners from africa
and europe
to secure a peace deal that everyone
thought was impossible this
deal between the north and the south
after two and a half million people died
and as we do so often once the sort of
the biggest
mountain has been surmounted we sort of
just go off to the next thing and when
that
peace deal was signed and we left the
sudanese to their own devices
for the last four and a half years we've
seen
slowly steadily ratching back on many of
the commitments that were made
historic commitments that were made in
this deal and so
as george said the wake up call for
better or worse
came about two months ago in washington
and in the
united nations security council and
people started saying my god
if we don't urgently attend to this
we're going to lose
that extraordinary that historic deal
and and the south will be an inferno
again
george let me ask you because you went
in 2004 with your dad
a journalist five and again 2005. and uh
you've been
twice now with nbc i think and
and once with the you and before to
cartoon okay so
that's a fun trip how do you see the
current diplomacy with
president obama offering incentives
to the north the government to
improve u.s relations to
unfreeze assets to do other kinds of
things that
are wanted by the north if there's a
peace deal where does that leave
for example darfur where you've also
well i think i think that the the
therefore has to be painted into that
exact same negotiation it's not
something that can just be
hey if you just play a little nice
you're going to get some nice carrots
out of it there has to be some
real uh you know they have to there has
to be a tremendous amount of effort
look in any negotiation and that's what
this is it is a negotiation
um there are going to be people you're
going to both sides are going to have to
give
there is no question about the fact that
the border that
that is you know that both sides want is
going to be somewhere that
neither of them are particularly happy
when they finally decide on it
the people who are allowed to vote are
going to be disputed and it's never
going to be exactly what
one person one group is happier the
other group is happy
but it's going to require negotiation i
mean look you can do this
either way we can we can pick this up in
five or six months when
uh you know thousands and thousands if
not hundreds of thousands of people can
be
killed and we can mop this mess up or we
can do everything we can to
to stop before it happens we have an
actual opportunity to stop it
and that requires making some hard
choices including
diplomacy that means working with people
that aren't so savory
and that's a hard hard thing to do it's
certainly not an easy thing politically
to do
but uh but both sides meaning both sides
of our political spectrum uh are willing
to
start to talk about gray areas and i
think that that's the only way we're
gonna get to move forward john if you
agree
with that scenario who can play that
role who can put on the pressure where
are the
levers to incentivize both sides
to give up something you use both words
in the question and i think both words
are
apropos there are incentives and there
are pressures that we still have at our
disposal
and those are not static actors we need
to
i mean leverage is built it is not it
doesn't grow in trees it is built
through
you know serious engagement and
diplomacy and creative thinking
and in this case you have to assess in
every case you have to assess oh what do
the people want what are their interests
and in the case of khartoum the the
ruling party in khartoum
it's very clear um you know bashir
doesn't want to be the guy that lost the
south
and get nothing out of it he's got to
have a fairly significant
oil well-sharing deal over a course of a
number of years
for him to at least get something out of
the thing he needs
a normalization with the united states
he doesn't want a new state in the south
appearing
uh and the and the uh and and the us
suddenly goes you know what we'll just
be good buddies with the people in the
south
and let's get let's go for a regime
changing cartoon this is worst case
scenario
so you have you have a number of
interests that you then assess and you
say okay so
if we're going to as mediators have an
influence on the calculations of the
parties at the table
we have to take into account these
interests and figure out
what the what kind of and back to the
words carrots and sticks we can deploy
and the carrots have to be meaningful
and not this little agricultural program
that we're announcing
no you have to talk about at the end of
the rainbow
as long as there's a resolution in
darfur and the south as george is saying
you're going to get this and it's going
to be significant and we're normalizing
relations
and all the human rights purists are
going to be sickened by the fact
including us but you swallow it uh
because we've got because
peace is more important than anything
peace with some level of sort of
damocles accountability hanging over
people's heads with the icc
but then you have on this other side of
the fence you've got to be ready to
deploy
sticks and as as some of the people on
the
in on our trip said from on the field
call them clubs not sticks because at
this point
you know little little toothpicks aren't
going to mean anything to these guys
we got to be willing to go after assets
in a very significant way
a lot of money's been made by this oil
through this oil
and we've got to be looking at a series
of escalating
uh consequences that would occur for any
party no matter who it is
uh that'd be willing to plunge the south
the north and south back to war
as a long-time human rights advocate
what are you
willing to give up some sudanese friends
have been saying to me lately you know
we're worried
what has happened to john garang the
former leader of the southern political
and military movement what what's
happened to his vision
of a democratic sudan you know and what
given the positive noises that have come
out from
some u.s negotiators about the
domestication
plans that the north has announced for
darfur you know
what what are you willing to give up to
get peace what is what is peace worth
yeah it's in the end of the day uh you
can't let perfection be the enemy the
good i think
you know what what the vision of the sea
the comprehensive peace agreement that
john grang and and uh
alice mentaha negotiated with a lot of
help from the united states and africa
uh uh the vision uh was at least from
grang's side
was that there would be this country
called called you know sudan that would
be
that would transform itself
democratically through the
through a uh sharing of wealth and power
none of that happened
during the last four and a half years of
the emperor four and three quarters of
the years of the implementation this
deal
the regime the authorities in khartoum
had the chance and this was
from francis deng's sort of books onto
transformed into the peace agreement
let's make unity attractive that was the
egyptians and saudis and everybody said
this is this is the strategy
we want the world to pursue saying who
francis ding is yeah
the former minister of state of state
for foreign affairs in sudan in a long
time
uh i mean i'm sure everybody knows him
in here he's a very uh
very uh esteemed senior diplomat in the
international community
and you know this idea that that
democratic transformation can occur in
sudan
but the sudanese authorities are having
none of it it's an autocratic state they
will
do everything they can to maintain power
by any means necessary
and that does not include any form of
democratic transformation
so the southerners are like what do you
want us to do we're gone
and the darfurians now they've had their
seven years of fighting and you've got
now some voices whereas five three four
years ago we noticed we were there
no no darfurian was talking about
self-determination or independence now
some of them are starting to talk about
it because
the the the state in in uh the
government in
in khartoum uh has ruled so uh
autocratically and
and so exclusion and so exclusionarily i
don't think that words allowed in the
cfr
but uh but you know i mean that that
reality has been very very clear we
would love to see democratic
transformation sitting here in
washington d.c in sudan
but it's up as they say to the sudanese
so of course we want to
build all we can into the peace process
that
would unfold with the under u.s auspices
or at least with u.s involvement
pushing for the the windows that you can
of opportunity for
for democratization but we have to be
realistic who we dealing with here
kenya's general sambao who was in
washington last week who was a
lead negotiator in the kenya's envoy and
it was highly acclaimed for having held
everybody's feet to the fire
both sides in sudan and the
international community
but he expressed lots of concern when he
was here last week i mean he said
that neither the north nor the south can
account for the oil revenues that have
come in
since the cpa that there's no political
will that he can discern
on either side to deal with any of the
yet outstanding issues
and that the south has no institutional
capacity to govern or to do anything
else
what have you seen in your travels well
they're they're it's certainly
infinitely further along than it was um
three years ago the south i mean they
really have made some movements
so can you be specific well they've
gotten to the point when we met with the
u.n the people
that we met within the u.n some of the
people that i've seen there years ago
you know
they're setting up you know you got to
remember that you know you have to find
a way
there's banking that has to work you
know there's roads
there's infrastructure that has to be
built there's a lot of that you're
seeing
big signs of that even in uh uh ebier
we saw you know roads being built there
were government basic government i mean
there's coming up basic administrative
structures
and they have each you know there is
there's a it's infinitely further than
it was when we were there the last time
it was in
in real shambles it's still going to be
you know a herculean
task to try to get an election off it's
really a big deal and it's going to be
very hard
and every single day we wait it's going
to be harder but
the truth is this what we saw also was a
very resolute
people we saw people who have for
generations
been enslaved and been sold and been
tortured and been murdered and raped
who in 2005 won the opportunity
one piece and won the opportunity to
vote for their own independence
and january 9th they are going to vote
for their independence and they
are willing to die for it and that was
to a man
and woman there and so
if we underestimate uh how strongly they
feel about this
then we're going to be doing a great
disservice to that to that region
because
there is going to be a very strong
reaction can the voting be pulled off
can it happen yeah i mean the people
we're not you know experts on polling
but the people we met with
who were going to be having to pull this
minor miracle off
said there's still time um it's not
going to be the
technically perfect election people
would want to see but
it is ads or anything yeah
are there ballot boxes are there voting
materials all that stuff is being
printed produced and just
beginning to be you know shipped from
wherever they're producing it to sudan
that will then be transshipped it's
it's a i mean the word herculean may be
an understatement
and what what these guys are up against
but you know i mean they just had an
election in april
it's not like this is virgin territory
they they had an election in april for
presidential and local elections yeah a
lot of problems but they went through
this process and part of why so many
millions of dollars were invested in
april
into that process even though everybody
said this is not going to be a fair free
and fair election
is because they wanted to to get the
machinery to start to oil the machinery
that would be required for the january
referendum and i think
again you got to give people some some
credit for
putting a lot of investing a lot of time
and effort into this in the united
nations and other governments that have
done a lot of work on this
it doesn't mean that we're starting from
zero there's actually an infrastructure
in place we've got the largest
peacekeeping force in the world
it's going to be deployed to get the
materials out there and get to vote
you know will it happen on january 9th
perfectly and stuff like that well
flip a coin but i do think that that
there's a chance
and as long as there's a chance we've
got to do everything we can to make it
happen
let's assume that it does what happens
on january 10th
as you know the religious community was
very
instrumental in helping the bush
administration begin to take action in
sudan began to pay attention
now the ecumenical religious community
from sudan
and from africa are engaged in a very
vigorous
international campaign they're calling
it ringing the alarm bells they're
talking about the ticking time bomb
a delegation is in new york now they met
with ban ki-moon
secretary general of the u.n yesterday
they are coming to washington next week
and they are saying that what faces them
in
sudan is a kind of rwanda-like moment
they're saying what all of us in the
international community are dealing with
is the chance to know before something
happens
that it's imminent and that it can be
stopped unlike rwanda
they say we know this one is coming so
do you agree with that is it is it that
dire and
and just again what happens on january
10th well here's the thing it doesn't
matter whether
i agree or not you know um uh it was
actually secretary clinton who called it
a ticking time bomb
uh the president has weighed in on in
the exact same way the cia said that
this is the next place
where the greatest possibility of
atrocities including and up to
genocide um this is a you know it
is a looming threat and if it's
75 if it's 50 and we didn't make
every effort possible to avoid it then
um then again we've done a great
disservice what happens january
10th look i was at the darfur rally
which by the way we relate to i mean
it's an important thing you said which
is you know we were late to the congo we
were late to the north south we were
late to
darfur we were late to rwanda
we have an opportunity to be ahead of
this in one way or another we have an
opportunity to be ahead of it and if we
don't do everything we can
politically diplomatically to try to
stop it
what happened after the rally in
washington and everybody even though it
was
way late everybody felt great and we all
joined arms and everybody marched home
darfur's done we fixed it you know and
the truth is
it wasn't and it what is required is
sustained
constant uh work very hard to do it's
hard to do in this day and age
uh where we you know we all
join hands to help haiti for a week or
two or pakistan for a week or two and
then
we're on to the next news story in the
next news cycle
it's a very hard thing it requires all
of us and all of the people in the media
and all of the people who actually feel
a responsibility to do more than just
the headlines and it's a hard thing it's
sustained one of the things that church
leaders are trying to call attention to
is what they feel is the vulnerability
of the million and a half or so
internally displaced people many from
the south in the north
and an unknown number of people from the
north in the south
did you discuss this on your trip yeah i
mean we
you know it's going to be a big problem
uh you know
just in terms of voting you know think
about it like this
you know you don't really know where the
border is yet we're still arguing over
that so there's going to be some dispute
over all of that
then you've got depending on uh how
the you know the north decides to count
heads
if it's if it's it's helpful they have
five hundred thousand
south sudanese in south sudanese in the
north or they have five million
as the vote is coming up they have five
million um
they don't have it's probably a million
million and a half
and they're not going to come down south
to vote you know they're not going to
make it it's a long way
and uh and they're going to face a lot
of intimidation in voting so
again there's this is uh there are
incredible
complex issues we talked to president
salvakir about that
today he felt like that that wouldn't be
decisive in any way
but all of those things are going to be
complicated but again
um it it's it's a problem until we
fix it you know i mean that's a great
thing about not just americans it's a
great thing about what we're doing now
what we're able to do now is
um uh you know diplomacy you know
at the end of every war you still got to
it's still appomattox you still got to
sit down and sign something
you know do you think the president and
the members of congress that you talked
to today
are ready to do that i think they are
now
i think they have been for about for the
last couple of months i think that i
think that what happened was a couple of
months ago
they were you know listen there's a lot
going on in the world and there they've
got
two wars to deal with and an economy and
plenty of issues in an election
all those kind of issues take up a lot
of space um
but i think somewhere around two months
ago or so
everybody looked around and said you
know wait a minute what's going on
and you can really feel the change you
could feel it almost immediately
we'd been planning this trip for about
two and a half or three months and when
we first started talking about it
the vacuum it was a vacuum and a vacuum
is a very
you know uh omar bashir really likes a
vacuum
vacuums are good for him he gets things
done um
and so we need to turn some lights on
and and you know make it a little harder
it was really remarkable today to to
listen to
president united states have such a
command over the intricacies of the
prosp the negotiations process now very
heartening to us
to see how engaged he is how he engaged
his administration it's very different
than what it was two or three months ago
as george is saying but
you know we'll take it when we get it
it's late but it's not too late and so
uh you know and and there's not only an
understanding intellectual comprehension
but a real i felt uh
resolve on the part of the president and
each one of the
members of congress that we spoke with i
mean it's it's across aisles
there's a real clear agreement
that we have to do much more than what
we're doing now willingness to do much
more
but a curiosity or a searching for what
exactly
would make a difference and that's part
of what we're doing is
not only raising the alarm bell but
throwing out some ideas
right now that might actually help move
the process along
there's a whole you will always hear you
know
which is why the united states and why
sudan and what
we're there i mean we spend almost a
billion dollars a year there
anyway so you know this
this is something that uh requires no
money and no
american lives right now um
so we can do it now or we can mop it up
we can we can triage this
afterwards and so to us it seems like
our job is to sort of just
yell it you know there was a we stayed
in a
uh we were in these huts we kept staying
in the really interesting places to stay
and uh we were roommates by the way
we're roommates
snores
he does other things
i don't know what that meant i just said
it i'm sorry three to the wolves
three under the bus it was cold
it's lonely all right so you're using
this is not allowed in council for
relations this is simply
oh this is actually council on forums
i'm a new member i'm proud to be a
member of the councilman you're you're
using your voice to try to weigh in let
me ask you you got to know about the
the hud thing you tell everybody well no
all right there was
there was a handwritten note that sort
of told you what to do in case of an
emergency they'll
blow a horn and you stay inside your hut
and don't come out until they blow their
own again
and then it says in the case of fire run
outside and scream fire fire fire
and we were we were laughing and
thinking well that's about the most
logical thing i've ever read in my life
and then you know we're getting on the
plane we're coming back and we're
laughing about it and then you sort of
feel like
you know you want to go everywhere
across the united states and across
england and across egypt and everywhere
and go fire fire fire i mean it's the
most
logical thing all right a final why
question
to either or both of you you mentioned
uh
zaire congo in eastern congo
five or six million people have died in
the past
six or seven years so why not congo why
sudan is just
just because this is a moment where you
can make a difference in sudan
and will you roll on to something else
afterwards uh once
once we've established peace in sudan i
don't
i think we're we've been working he's
worked on it we've we've uh worked on
this
on the congress together they're the two
biggest human rights and humanitarian
crises in the world
there is a moment now in sudan that is a
decisive moment that could
potentially with the proper diplomatic
intervention
prevent the loss of millions of lives
it's urgent
congo bleeds on we'll go you didn't know
this but we're going together soon
and and uh you know we're going to keep
working on that one too i had some goat
and gomo once that was
fantastic i see he's been there he's
done that all right we're going to open
this
we'll keep working on both to members i
can't believe it or not you can't see
very well from up here where people are
who they are i'm going to
call on you mostly at random i need to
tell you to
speak into the mic wait for the
microphone speak directly into it
and if you want to ask a question i'm
going to take one at a time
so please say your name and who you're
affiliated with
don't ask a question that's already been
asked and don't make a statement
and finally be very concise because i
will intervene to make sure we get as
many questions in as possible
and i learned the secret handshake
thank you my name is barbara slavin i'm
an independent journalist um
john nice to see you mr clooney nice to
see you
what are the chinese what am i not mr
prendergast
what happened i'm tired of this all
right for the record
disrespect on the rodney dangelfield of
the human rights community
i've only seen mr clooney on the screen
before so he's mr clooney
um what are the chinese up to because
the united states we give money but the
trade relationship with the u.s
is as my grandmother would say bupkus uh
the chinese are the ones who
who really hold the strings uh in terms
of oil so
are you trying to convince them to do
something because it would seem that
they have the most to lose
of uh foreign powers if this goes down
badly well i mean
we i've made trips to china john's been
there plenty of times we've had
you know you can't really shame you know
them
into it and uh you know they're pretty
big country with big needs
and they need oil and there's a lot of
oil there right now it's the third
largest
oil supplier out of africa so it's a big
number and it's all
you know you can go there and see
chinese workers uh in backs of trucks
you know
going all through south sudan it's a big
issue
and you know but rather than you know
the the tact of trying to say
shame on you guys for not paying
attention to humanitarian
issues hasn't been very effective you
know you don't leave
people away to win and i always find in
any negotiation i've ever been in
um you got to find a way to let somebody
be able to go home and say i got
something out of it
um the answer seems to me to be
when we go to abia and you're sitting
there with these
uh with the people who've been attacked
just
you know less than two years ago and
killed
massacred the whole town um
uh you know their answer would be
well we're about you know 10 kilometers
from a bunch of
oil wells and this will be nigeria
and you know this these aren't going to
be conventional wars and the south is
armed i mean remember this is a very
different time than it was
seven or eight years ago north and south
the south has some tanks and they got
planes and this is going to be much
bloodier and much harder
much more hardcore and they're going to
go after oil wells chinese oil wells
and so if they don't want to interrupt
the flow of oil and you could say that
to the egyptians as well with the water
rights
water flowing north they have a vested
interest
in not having a war truly a vested
interest so
rather than going to him saying shame on
you you're doing poorly
you know we need to have a again robust
diplomacy
saying look you guys you're in for some
real a real mess in terms of oil flow
so get involved what are they doing
you know it's it's it's one it's such
low diplomatic low-hanging fruit
uh china i mean i just want to know what
georgia said there's just so much
even though we come at it so differently
the united states and china
we have the exact same interest in
seeing stability in the south
and uh it it it's
i can't quite comprehend why we haven't
been the united states hasn't been much
more forward-leaning
with all the disputes and all the issues
that divide beijing and washington these
days
not to send a senior envoy with a very
positive message to say let's work on
this together
let's go back to khartoum together into
juba together and make sure
that in support of the african union
mediation china and the united states
the two countries in the world that have
the most influence in sudan
can bring different forms of influence
whether it's the good cop bad cop
whatever
the scenario is let's work together on
this and it's
and you know in our times we've both
gone to the security council and met
with them and
and and addressed them and and we've
told the chinese very directly about
the uh the implications of
non-involvement on this one that if
in fact as he's saying there's
conflagration the first targets are
going to be the chinese oil
installations
the southerners aren't stupid i mean
they could fight a conventional war for
the next 50 years and get bludgeoned and
the whole thing would be destroyed the
whole south would be destroyed or
they can fight an asymmetrical war where
they go straight for the
economic assets i mean which one are
they going to do let's
you mean no they know what they're going
to do so
uh so china you know it's it's a long
learning curve because they're sources
of diplomatic information sorts of
information on the ground or the
diplomats in khartoum we're not telling
him that
so so i just feel like it's again late
but not too late
we ought to be sending a senior senior
team
donald and mcdonough or somebody in the
in that hemisphere in that stratosphere
uh uh to to beijing to talk about how we
can work on this that's a concrete
policy recommendation
uh way in the back
thank you sonia shot with global vision
venezuela i would like to know how you
will characterize the response
of the international community to your
appeal
and if you have a specific
response from latin america thank you
you can talk on latin america we know
that the international response has been
tepid um you know the problem with what
the united states has has uh pulled off
pretty much all of the sanctions we have
you know we're running out of a lot of
sticks
england's got some sticks and france has
some stick you know they're people that
are still doing business
that you can you know believe me uh uh
omar al-bashir is not
buying things with sudanese pounds you
know
he's buying them with with british
pounds and with euro
and and you know the international
community could be looking for those
those funds and freezing them that's a
that's a first
good step again another policy step that
you could be doing
to truly say okay you guys want to play
it's going to we're going to make it
a much smaller playground for you every
day
so the international community has not
stepped up enough
part of the job of all of us who care
about this issue
is to continue to make it a a a priority
and that's our job
and uh latin america what do you know
i'm pretty sure what i'm about to tell
you is a true story but i'm not entirely
sure i've never let the facts
undermine a good argument but i believe
it was costa rica
that was the president of the security
council during the month in which
the issue of the uh the referral
of sudan to the international criminal
the
dark case of darfur to the international
criminal court was taken up
now what you get from the united us
diplomats and british diplomats and
french
we can't do anything in the security
council because of the chinese and the
russians they say it to you every day
on 50 different issues the costa ricans
painstakingly oh god i hope this is true
painstakingly cobbled together
an absolute majority in the council
neutralized the chinese and russians
believe it or not
and got the the united states to shift
its vote even though it's virulent
opposition to the previous
administration to the icc
to a neutral one and was able to
where and they were able to to to push
the case of darfur to the icc
it's an example uh at times and ocampo
being from latin america
has i think been instrumental in getting
certain countries at certain junctures
to stiffen the spine of the in the
united nations
to keep accountability in the mix you
know we could walk around all day and
talk about peace
and and can everybody just get along but
at some point
uh there has to be a break into this
cycle of impunity in in sudan
uh people have to respond for uh to
these crimes against humanity that have
been committed and uh
and so the the latin americans have i
think been very very
uh positive in that particular aspect
the of the overall problem
so if it's not a true story they have a
chance to make it true they can step up
right there in the middle
other side
i'm howard we are from the center for
strategic and international studies csis
having an election for independence in
the south
in a context of almost total lack of
institutions in the south is a formula
for disaster
and it's also a formula for a failed
state and of course we all know that
institutions are going to take 50 or 100
years to develop so how do you two see
this uh developing over time is this
is this going to call for a a 50-year
occupation on the part
of us or the un or the african union or
how do you see this developing over the
long term
once presumably some diplomatic efforts
are done to deal with the
immediate situation you know if you if
you go back and look at where where the
united states was
uh you know most of africa is now 50 or
60 years old
uh as as independent nation states and
if you look at where the united states
was we were
in the midst of an ethnic cleansing
against native american population we
had
our economies being fueled by a
transatlantic slave trade we hadn't even
fought our
civil war yet which was the one of the
bloodiest and per capita terms in the
history of the
world i mean you know you got to start
somewhere
uh the sudanese people are not the
southern sudanese people are not going
to be denied
uh their their their independence and uh
you know we can make all the
intellectual arguments we want to
historical arguments we want to but
that's going to happen and so what we
need to do is figure out okay
what are as you're asking what are the
essential institutions
that are most important to secure some
level of stability
and some level of service delivery some
level of authenticity
legitimacy for uh for for basic
government
institutions in the united states by far
in a way
is the biggest player in this and i
think since the bush administration
through the obama administration there's
been a
bipartisan commitment on the part of
congress to fund
significant institution building
programs that many african states
at the time of independence in the 50s
and 60s did not have the advantage of
having
now the problem is you've got this sort
of damocles hanging over their heads
up in khartoum if there is indeed an
independent state which is a big if
uh clean uh that they still here still
got the ethiopia eritrea scenario
as a possibility but i'm i'm optimistic
frankly because i think if we can get
through this period
if diplomacy wins the day if a
negotiated settlement addressing
everyone's interest
there's a lot of money to be made and
this is not an insignificant factor and
if they can figure out a way to share
that
and they can figure out a way to where
to place that border and then stick the
pylons in there
and they can figure out a way to coexist
as two separate entities and we can
invest as much as we possibly can in
other states
and get the the arab league particularly
we've made a lot of
comments about what they will do and
we've got to actually have them come
through now
because a stable southern border will be
good for khartoum and good for
oil production i think you know it's got
a shot it's got a shot it's going to
it's going to muddle through and there's
going to be terrible inter-ethnic
conflict and you're shaking your head
because you're like what does this ngo
guy know
but you know i've been going there for
25 years and uh
and i the one thing the southern
sudanese have is a very very clear
desire for freedom and for independence
and again we get in the way of that
that's just going to be more warfare so
let's get on with it let's build let's
help support the state building
enterprise that's going to occur as you
say over the next 50 to 100 years just
like existed in the united states
hi sarah margon with senator feingold
you talked a little bit about
um some of the incentives and
suggestions that you had for u.s policy
i'd be interested to hear
your suggestions for some of the key
regional actors you mentioned egypt
chad uganda uh if you might speak a
little bit to those countries and what
role they can play
in the next 89 90 days but then also
after the referendum
such a dynamic you know go ahead no yeah
it's all right yeah you're better you
breathed inward very sharp here that
means your head is smarter at this time
chad is a is already participating
obviously because
everything's spilling over the border um
the water i mean yeah well egypt is the
i mean obviously that we talked about
that before
egypt in particular you know uh we
we went to egypt and met with eventually
a suzanna bark
this was on the darfur issue but um you
know
egypt is not uh jumping to get in on
this
you know they're not hoping to save all
these problems but the truth of the
matter is
um this you know they're growing and
they're at the very end of the the nile
pipeline
and they're starting to lose water and
water is becoming an issue
they're going to have some negotiating
uh to do to make sure they get it
and that and that gives um uh south
sudan some
leverage and i think that that's that's
a place that
if if you were to ask most of the
experts that
we've talked to uh where the best places
to go where the most leverage is it's
first china of course and then the
second place is egypt
um in terms of regional powers chad's
hard to do you know they're having their
own problems obviously
and people forget you know in 1983 when
when the war started
to the north and the south the um the
first two targets of the spla the the
southern
uh army was uh were uh
chevron's oil installations which they
successfully drove chevron out right
away
uh and then the second target was this
crazy it was i think at the time
somebody might correct me because again
facts
the largest machine in the world the
largest moving machine in the world
was digging a canal called the john gley
canal which
john garang wrote his phd dissertation
on it at
iowa university grinnell about the
jungle
scheme and it was an attempt at the time
by sudan to create
this canal that would draw that would
pull some of the waters that lie
stagnant in the sud swamp in southern
sudan wasted
uh uh hydroelectricity and
and irrigation in egypt having it just
sitting there in sudan
and the canal was going to drive that
water uh northward
uh into into egypt
egypt's interest in the long run
is a is some kind of an arrangement in
southern sudan
that can recreate that that
that northward that increased northward
flow of the now for the reason that
george said is that
their 20-year plans for industrial
development and agricultural development
completely depend on massively increased
flow of water
which in fact is going the other way
because ethiopia and rwanda and kenya
and tanzania everybody else
south of egypt wants to use this water
and the ethiopians particularly
building huge irrigation schemes so so
what egypt's chance is to find a way
to cut a deal with the people who are
living in that place whether it's in
united sudan or in southern sudan
so that they can recreate this this
economic
lifeline which the canal will represent
and they'll redo it and they'll find
that machine and they'll rebuild it and
do it again
uh because that is the future and so so
i think egypt is a major player sarah
and and in ethiopia um you know behind
the scenes
in these negotiations that they succeed
or fail melissa now
is going to be part of this and he's the
one that has
the most contact with uh with both
parties you know some have contact with
one and some have contact with the other
he has both
i think that museveni is going to play a
role because he has influence with
with the splm and then a few of the arab
states uh
with their relationships with khartoum
so those are the countries that matter
those are the countries that the united
states has to be putting a full court
diplomatic press on now
to ensure that we're all going in the
same direction
right here
hi my name is reba carruth i'm an
independent scholar i'd like to commend
the panel for the work that they're
doing very quickly i'd just like to
ask you um do you think it would be good
for the united states to reaffirm its
leadership
with its core principle of the unity of
peoples and equality of peoples
and build the the capacity building
for the government the emerging
government and the nation
of sudan around that because that way
the trust in the united states to
be able to deliver not just hope but but
a vision
that can be embraced by the sudanese
people
could be built and i think that's the
key here because in a way
i think what you're saying is really the
key to all of this
the black sudanese people are indigenous
people to that area
the problem with them is that they have
resources
that they have never had ownership of
and
so it's a bigger issue it's a it's a
slavery issue it's a race and ethnic
relations issue
and i think going forward america has
tools
not just on the market side not just on
the policy and government building side
but on the unity of of people's
reconciliation and the integration of
nation side so could you
speak a little more to that both of you
actually not just uh
well it's a tricky thing you know it's a
very you know
what you're trying what you have to try
to do in in this negotiation
you have to try and separate yourself
from some of those
situations because people have been
living across borders for
generations now so it's not as simple as
sort of you know
christian and muslim and you know the
same you know different colors and
you know uh there there is some absolute
truth in the fact that
if you go to abbie a you'll see the
people there
you know nobody gave a damn about that
area until they found oil i mean the
truth is the messeria would come down
and let their
you know their cattle would graze and
then they'd leave nomadic people nomadic
people no one cared they all
getting fights every once in a while you
know but it wasn't a big deal
uh it has become you know a rather big
deal and it has become a rather big deal
because there's oil
now when you talk to those people who
were killed two years ago
all of the people were killed the
families who whose lives were ruined two
years ago
um they believe and this is a very big
part of it that they say
uh who put this oil in the ground god
and god gave it to us as as you know as
a gift because of how much we've
suffered and it's ours
and they believe that very strongly so
that's why negotiations
are going to be very difficult they're
saying no we're not sharing any of it
this is on our land and we're not
sharing any of it
that's why we keep going back to the
idea of
when we talk about robust negotiations
it means getting people in going
i get it and it means people listen it
means
at some point bringing in people they
trust
the the from the from the last agreement
you know
uh um senator danforth the
uh colin powell and bring them in you
know
bring i don't wanna undercut uh um
general gration at all but
you know at some point they trust those
guys and if they say listen
just let's just work this out so we can
have peace
you you'd have a better shot with them
so i mean look it's a very complicated
issue
again you're you're right but it's you
know if
to deal with it in terms of um
race and religion gets puts us in a very
sort of complex
and much more difficult place to ever
solve you know
than just saying let's let's work on it
from these
these borders that were established that
for some reason were established
50 years 56 years ago you know i find
that to be part of the trouble
what only only footnote i'd add is that
the
sort of one way to conquer concretize a
unifying vision
is in the form of these post-referendum
negotiations that are
supposed to be occurring now um this is
the the race you know to
whether whether diplomacy will will
overcome
the the winds of war but uh but these
post-referendum negotiations will
establish the terms of the relationship
between
the north and the south once the south
is an independent state which it will be
one way or the other
and so that is a place where you know
how wealth is shared how powershell how
security is
how security arrangements are met uh how
they deal with all the all the
complicated issues of banking and
financial relationships
you know twenty percent of the people of
the north and the south
depend in some way shape or form on
border
on access to the border whether it's
pastoral communities that georgia's
talking about or it's
it's agricult migrant labor uh or it's
cross-border trade i mean that's a one
out of every five people in sudan
affected by that border
so having some kind of a vision about
how they they work together in the
future is going to be key and
and these negotiations that are going to
be ongoing under him becky that we're
arguing ought to be reinforced with
higher level support
i forgot sorry um you're doing good
you're in a good chair but uh yeah and i
think
that's the place where we can do it
television middle east broadcasting
center good to see you
again john um if i may ask us
and and mrs look at me really i don't
know i think
i know him for a long time so but you
could have said mr prendergast i'm just
saying
you had your chance nadia come on ant mr
clooney as well
um as you know the the talks in alice
abba has collapsed
and both the government and the spla
came and acknowledged that
do you honestly believe that the
referendum can take place um
over i mean over iba the the um
the negotiation collapse do you think
that referendum can take place with that
ibe considering that the time period
we're talking about 90 days
and also if i may add um you might be
aware that the arab league issued a
statement talking about
um in principle supporting the um the
idea of referendum
but they want severely against cessation
and they think it's going to be a bad
example in africa and particularly in
sudan
are you worried about interference from
um neighboring state
despite the incentives that you talked
about
i hate two-part questions because i
never remember the first time actually
that was a three-part
series now do you remember any of them
um the first one was sorry it's not
personal
the first one was about uh
well can you can you have a peace
referendum with uh
ignoring avia somehow we're pushing it
off top i mean i think somewhere along
the way there's gonna have to be some
some of this is probably going to be
delayed iba's of
you know so if there's anybody here who
doesn't understand it there's two
referendums there's a referendum for the
north and south and then there's a very
specific vote at the same time the same
day
for the area of iba which is the
contested
basically border where all the oil is so
for now can you have for example a soft
border
and move forward this talks about uh
sort of a demilitarized zone in the
middle
in certain targeted areas and guarded by
the unanimous forces
um you know again those are all things
that that can be negotiated and you have
to try when you say the talks broke down
i've never seen a negotiation in
anything and listen i make you know
i i have to negotiate with warner
brothers
you know it can take you know talks
break down it's just
you know they broke down this time
because they were starting to agree on a
border but they started to disagree more
and more on
who's allowed to vote okay well then
bring in the next
group bring in the a bigger you know
more robust group
and let's go again just keep going um
what we are
sure of is that having talked to the
president today
that uh he wasn't disheartened by the
by the news that the broken that the
talks had broken down because he
believes
that by next week they can be back up
and and talking again
and uh and i think that's how listen
none of us are right now we're not going
to figure it out you know this gentleman
was right
if if this all if it works out and they
get a peaceful
you know uh border and everybody it's
the north and south it could end up
being a failed state yeah probably could
happen i don't know
what we do know is if we sit back and do
nothing at this point
and just turn our backs and walk away
then there's a very good
possibility that half a million you know
half a million to a million to a hundred
thousand pick your number i don't care
uh innocent men women children could die
can't so we have to start to do as much
as we can as fast as we can
to try and help them first first you put
out the fire
and then you go in and you start
replacing the furniture you know
and uh one thing i would say and and
kurt ann curry came with us on this trip
and we all heard very clearly
loudly and clearly from the people of
obje they're you know they're voting on
the ninth if they don't vote on the
night they're going to
declare as the southerners if they get
denied a vote a
unilateral declaration of independence
the abe the dink of the iba region are
going to join the south
and that's where they are and it's very
clear there's no focus group needed we
got the
we got the word and so um i mean
the so in in other words if your
question is you know can you possibly
have a referendum
between the north uh for the south but
then not have one for abia with no
consequence no
um i think that that what
our message is if there is anyone and
you tell me if this is our bottom line
that you know at the end of the day a
grand bargain is going to have to be
struck a package deal is going to have
to be struck
negotiated that involves the interests
of all these different groups
and abia's status in some way shape or
form is going to be part of that
negotiation and whether it
it actually has a referendum which would
be rather easy to hold
unlike the south which is going to be a
logistical nightmare but abi
is a contained area that if they
actually agree on requirements you could
do it
from a technical perspective without
difficulty it's not a technical issue
though
so there's going to be extreme
difficulty
so but if if there is so the bottom line
for us is that rba is part of the larger
issues between the north and the south
and that that has to be negotiated
and it's clear from the people there
that if you try to negotiate
negotiate their away their right to
self-determination
there will be war and and again
when we say it's our uh view that's
two days in a row sitting with uh
president kier
and having him say abby if
if it is if it's given away uh
that's war period you know so that's it
wasn't there was no
oh i said so that means that youth the
south stands with rba
and he said the san the south stands
without being so you know
and i understand just because this is a
council we wouldn't do this normally for
other audiences but
there's one level of detail that's
necessary why is everybody making such a
big deal about avi
well because the national congress party
the government cartoon
is using rba as a bargaining chip so you
know they
the longer they hold out on this issue
and
propose crazy ideas about who's going to
be allowed to vote in that
referendum the more they win themselves
in terms of possible flexibility or
forcing flexibility on the part of the
splm
on the border where the border is uh
and other aspects of those
post-referendum arrangements we talked
about
so there's they're basically suing for a
better deal and using iba as a
bargaining chip very cynically
and again it's a very dangerous game
they're arming militias on the border
the guy
besides omar al-bashir we all know he
was indicted by the icc
well ahmed haroon was indicted by the
isis he's the governor of south quarter
fan right there on the border of abier
there's all kinds of reports about
militarizing some of these
militias that were the ones that were
doing the slave ratings and
slave rating in the 80s and 90s i mean
the history here is like
you know you just pass this prologue
watch out and this is like just a pool
of gasoline waiting for a match to
ignite it
alas we are out of time just say in 10
seconds each
what the global public should be doing
to help the policymakers see their way
well i think
the global public should be in any way
they can because you know this is a very
you know it's a tricky time first and
foremost
getting a hold of it's we've set up
things like we set up
sudan
not there's no there's no ties to it
there's no money in it we're not that
nobody's asked for money it's just
a a way of getting directly to the white
house through the email going
we support any and every effort that you
are willing to make to diplomatically
put an end to this
before it starts you can do that you
know some we can set it up and
it you know for for the new prime
minister in england we can set it up
um we set up you know we set them up
everywhere because first
and foremost what we know is everybody
wants to do something there's nobody
that doesn't want to help people and no
if
it's not going to cost you anything and
you're not going to risk lives of your
own people
why not of course you want to do the
right thing but but
you know there's senator lugar and
there's senator kerry and they want to
do the right thing
but what they need is political will
they need to be told
not only that they that they want to do
the right thing
but they should do the right thing and
that their constituency wants them and
demands them to do it
and that's political will and that is
every voice in the country and every
voice in
in europe and that's important that
wasn't 10 seconds sorry
he took my time i like it i'll i'll just
associate myself with that
people came for him and not me anyway so
let him have the last word
i was two times sexiest man alive i
don't want to say that
i wonder i want to remind just just a
second
oh what an exit thank you thank you
thank you
i want to remind everybody that this has
been on the record
you've got your marching orders and john
generous soul has donated copies of his
new book the enough moment
fighting to end africa's worst human
rights crimes which probably give you
more marching orders and
you can pick one up on your way out
thank you all and thank you very much
thank you thank you so much thank you
great great great
good job buddy hey brother
foreign